[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brandon steiner
recently launched athletedirect.com it's
about
athlete empowerment as well as unique
personal memorabilia for fans and
collectors directly from
players and coaches mark messier tom
coughlin sue bird doc gooden willie
randolph
and our next guest yankee manager aaron
boone giving them the ability to
monetize
their collections or brands uh aaron
good to talk to you again
uh what do you have what's your what's
your prized possession piece of sports
memorabilia
oh um
you know what it goes back to when i was
a little kid
so when i was when i was a kid growing
up
in in south jersey and i was 10 years
old
i got a maurice cheeks jersey mo cheeks
my all-time
favorite those great sixer teams of
obviously when moses malone finally came
and and they won the championship
mo cheeks was my guy when i was a kid
and i got this jersey
uh and it's it's the greatest gift i've
ever gotten in my life i still have it i
still throw it on every now and then
so i would say my mo cheeks jersey have
you ever met mo cheeks
i have um funny story um
so i was at a clippers game
in the off season and i was sitting
courtside
and um it was after i hurt my knee after
um in in the off season of 03 and 04 and
and mo was coaching
and i happened to get his attention
across the court and
and somebody walked me over there and i
got to meet him and everything i kind of
told him my story growing up and
everything so
yeah it was pretty neat so you were you
were fanboying him
yes absolutely absolutely but did you
keep anything when you hit the homer off
uh
wakefield when uh the yankees won the
world series uh
you well you guys went on to win the
world series but uh
or no you lost to the marlins right
yes oops sorry let's i'll try that again
when you hit the home run off wakefield
did you keep anything
from that game no so i actually gave my
bat to the hall of fame
um a fan that got the ball i ended up
meeting him and signing the ball for him
um you know i have the batting gloves
and everything from
from that but but no not i didn't really
keep much from that
um you know i i guess i have somewhere
in
a in a case you know the spikes i wore
the batting gloves but
um now with with this athlete's
directing
a lot of the things that i wear in
season during the season
you know sometimes my lineup card that i
keep in my pocket
my cut off hoodies and things like that
these are things that
it's amazing that people you know want
to want to grab these things
and and it's cool to be able to interact
in that way and
uh this is this is what this uh venture
with brandon's allowing us to do it's
pretty neat
yeah and you take control over your your
own gear
i i did you ever talk to wakefield about
that home run like how does that work
with
after after you're out of the game yeah
you ever had a conversation
so i've had a few conversations with tim
um
first of all tim's a great guy like
loves the game
um has been involved on the broadcast
side so i've i've had a number of
conversations with him
over the years um nothing about that
more just talking the game catching up
with each other uh
we don't really talk about that you know
he he uh
he he actually had my number he he owned
me uh
and i ran into him ran into one against
him because uh
man nothing uh thing danced all over the
place usually
he could still pitch i think aaron i
would think he could roll out there and
and and definitely get some outs you
know we don't really have any
knuckleballers in the game right now so
he'd be even more unique
and uh but but he was special and
and obviously uh you know had an amazing
career but
we've had some great conversations over
the years but basically just
uh you know talking like like old
friends
he's aaron boone the yankee manager did
you see the play with the
pirates in the cubs yesterday with javi
bias
yes i did how does that happen
you know i i think i think you get
caught up in the moment
uh a little bit first of all credit to
javi for
for getting a little creative and and
creating a distraction i think
you know it's sometimes you know as
manager coaches we go over these things
sometimes with
with things that you think are just
completely obvious you know
uh rules rules like uh
infield fly rule where something happens
in the moment that's different and
sometimes you react in a funny way and
and obviously
you know with the ball taking him off
the bag and as you start to chase javi
down the line you're like
what is this guy doing all of a sudden
though you see runners moving and
obviously he got a little
cluttered in the mind and and one of the
weirdest plays you'll ever see uh we'll
get to see now on
on a replay for uh for as long as we're
here but
the creativity by javi to create you
know confusion
um was amazing but obviously you know
in the end all you needed to do was step
on first even after contreras scored
what's the strangest thing you've seen
on a baseball field that's right
up there that's right up there um
you know danny graves i played with in
in cincinnati was a
really good closer with us uh we were uh
we were appealing a play at third base
and he was all
he actually was a great fielding pitcher
as well and fielded his position really
well
and uh so you know he gets on the rubber
steps off to appeal a third threw it
over my head and into the stands
that that didn't work out too well so
that was a pretty good one that i teased
danny about a lot
now your grandfather played your father
played your brother played
you know the the look of baseball now as
opposed to what you grew up with
right like it it's definitely different
yeah but how do you manage do you manage
differently than than you would if if
you were
managing 15 years ago 10 years ago
yeah i think so because i i think
there's just so much
more information available to you on a
daily basis and
you know how you're you know evaluating
players
opponents uh different matchups um
you know there's just there's just more
detailed involved and
and obviously it's a different game with
with um
you know the amount of power pitchers in
our game now especially
rolling out from the bullpen so it's
definitely changed and evolved and
and you got to try and keep up with it
as best you can as well as
you know doing our part to try and you
know as keepers of the game to
to try and do things that that do make
it more appealing
but is there always going to be a place
for pitchers like like if maddox was
pitching now or tom glavin's pitching
now
more finesse spotting what they do
living on the edges here
as opposed to these guys who just say
here it is
okay right go get it um first of all
when you're talking about great pitchers
like maddox and flavin
they they would adapt and they would you
know
no doubt figure figure things out i
would say the one thing
that's different when you mention those
guys and and you're talking to me
pl who played in the 90s and the 2000s
i would say one thing that's changed a
lot is the strike zone
the strike zone is much more north south
now um
there's probably some lower pitches
called strikes some higher pitches above
the waist called strikes that weren't
when i played
um but definitely east and west if
if if you're a inch or inch or so off
the plate
now and and that's called a strike you
know you're hearing about it
you know that that's off the plate now
whereas you know back in the
when i played again if a pitcher had
command
like maddox like lavin if you were
demonstrating you could hit the glove
two three four
even more inches off the plate sometimes
uh off the corner
you got that call on a lot of nights now
uh i don't think you'd get that on the
regular
who says something to you when you go
out and you start arguing with an
umpire and it it doesn't go well
like like who lets you know
what what what what are you doing uh a
different
you know obviously you you have your own
vantage point from the side where
obviously it's not perfect i don't have
the home but you get an idea of how
things are going
um and then it could be anyone that
if if if i'm starting to get uh worked
up about something or i feel like
something needs to be addressed i might
ask about a couple of specific calls
that i think
were were questionable and i want to i
want a little bit of color and a little
bit of context on all right what exactly
am i dealing with but dude kids do your
kids say something to you
when when you make it on the highlights
here aaron oh
um not really i think they kind of
laugh but um
you know sometimes you know i've had a
couple rants that obviously
a hot mic is has caught
you know when i'm dealing with my
children um
it's not the proudest moment some of the
some of the language i use i'm not
i don't regularly use that kind of
language so usually it's just in those
moments that
it gets me worked up like that but can't
you get your point across
without like kicking dirt or being
demonstrative can't you just go out and
just go
let me just talk to you here like yes
like
did you ever think about that approach
how much of this is for show
yeah i mean sometimes that happens i
could you know
you should you should get in the dugout
one time and i would like to see you go
out there and get your point across like
that in kind of dan patrick fashion yeah
but but aaron i'd go with a little humor
with my voice and i'd go out and i would
say uh hey joe
to joey hey joe joe come here i i'm just
trying to understand this just help me
because i
it feels like i'm getting squeezed here
a little bit and uh
i got to protect my guy i don't want to
make a big deal out of this look i got
great respect you're one of the great
manager or you're one of the great
umpires of old
i think the best umpire of all time but
aside from that can you help out garrett
cole i mean the guy is getting squeezed
a little bit here just
you know see it within your heart that
uh you can just call it the way it
should be called at least i think it
should be called and look if i'm out of
or
you know out of line you just tell me
joe you just tell me
how would that go erin i think that
would be tremendous
and i'm you know what i i'm going to
take that under advisement
and if i have to go out there the next
time i may do it in that
uh calm yes somewhat passive aggressive
you know i had to help mattingly because
mattingly would get tossed
and i said every time you get tossed you
have to send me
a part of your uniform i have the whole
uniform aaron
because he would get taught he said
there were times when he went out
knowing he was going to have to send me
his pants
and so he was he said i'd go out there
and i'm so mad and i know this is going
to cost me a piece of my uniform here
and i have a whole mannequin full of don
mattingly his
entire dodger uniform i have
that is tremendous yeah and we've added
the marlins uniform now to that as well
so when you go out there
just have that thought that that's right
dan patrick said
how about i just go out there and just
have a conversation
you know what i i'm absolutely gonna try
that and uh
i think that would be quite funny
especially if i got kicked out in the
process
completely calm yeah complimentary
and even say thank you if you get tossed
you know what thanks i
i'm sorry i interrupted the time here
and um
look i i am i apologize and i'm going to
go into uh
into the locker room right now and uh
and i hope i'm going to enjoy watching
the rest of the game and i i wish you
nothing but uh great things joe
uh love your work like i'm taking it
under advisement
okay i'm sure you are i think it would
be tremendous so instead of sending me a
piece of your uniform you're gonna have
it on uh
athletedirect.com so i'm not even see
what i did there
full circle aaron yep i like it i'm a
five
tool host they call me the the jeter of
host
well was jeter a five tool um
i mean one the power guy had a classic
five tool
but you know he had the six tool though
too
what was that just the intangible piece
oh i thought it had to do with the women
my bad
i thought like i like whoa where are we
going with this okay
all right we we should have hung up two
minutes ago right
we we should have yeah
oh yeah he was quite a teammate though
right
yeah he was
uh it's athletedirect.com see this is
the kind of demeanor you should have
when you go out to argue with an umpire
very good i'm definitely going out there
composed
complimentary pat him on the head maybe
uh it's great to talk to you and uh have
fun with this
um and uh thanks for joining us i
appreciate it dan take care
good sport aaron boone athletedirect.com
i didn't know what the sixth tool was